- We won't call it quits.
We'll call it the start.
(keys clacking)
(bright orchestral music)
- Please, don't talk to me
no more, Padraic.
- So obviously, you know,
I'd wanted to get Colin
and Brendan back together
since "In Bruges" days,
and I was sort of in a breakup-y
kind of situation back then
and just trying to explore
the sadness of that, you know,
as deeply sad as those things can be.
- You used to be nice, or
did you never used to be?
- [Waymond] I'm another version of him
from another life path, another universe.
I'm here because we need your help.
- Very busy today, no time to help you.
- We were grappling with the
question of how do we exist
in the chaos and the noise of modern life?
You know, like, how do you
make sense of any of it?
- We live in a world where
we're constantly distracted
by so many things, and one
of the only things we have
to give each other is our attention.
- You'll make your movies
and you will do your art
and you'll remember how it hurt.
So you know what I'm saying?
- All of my films I consider
to be personal films,
but I've never really made a movie
that is about a lived
experience as opposed
to just a metaphor to something else.
- I had never written
anything with anybody
and I didn't know how,
whether it would work.
I mean, it just sort of flowed out.
It was really, it was a fascinating thing,
and we had a blast.
- You wanna dance the mask,
you must service the composer.
You gotta sublimate yourself, your ego,
and yes, your identity.
- The old saying inspiration
is, you know, 90% sweat.
Incredible thing's gonna happen
when people come together
and they're all aligned for the same aim.
You have a chance then.
There's a lot of people
that work very, very hard.
You know, inspiration
is important, obviously,
but there's a certain
point where you just have
to be very lucky.
- If today was your last day alive,
what would you wish for?
- I have no idea.
- I almost look at filmmaking as like,
putting up sociological experiments
and trying to make an
interesting example when we fail,
why do we fail?
- Never argue with an idiot.
that'll only bring you down to their level
and beat you with experience.
(bright orchestral music)